What will happen.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Maybe that's what book big about.
Maybe bigfoot was about do let's,
let's create this mythical monster and have people afraid.
They don't want people to move in the woods.
The thing,
cause that's not good.
That's not good for the Nwa.
Oh,
you're the new little dog.
They want people to go into cities,
so they create these big firms.
If they're not doing it,
they should do it.
Create another.
That's it.
That's the most easy way.
Reason for believing in big foot I've ever heard.
That's so funny.
Thanks for,
it's been around forever though,
Dude.
They talked about it in the CIA's been going on forever and it was in the native
American culture before when I bet the Nazis did that.
Tabitha Nazis like have a bet.
If you go to Germany,
they have these mythical creatures that they created a scare people out of the
woods.
If they're not,
if they're not doing that,
damn,
they got to give me credit if they started doing it because that's a good
illuminati move right there,
right.
That's how crazy deep you have to be.
If you're a conspiracy theorist,
if you go so deep,
you think that the CIA was in the native American's before Columbus landed pro.
You don't even understand it had a different name.
It was a series of native art.
They taught the European,
maybe the CIA of the Apache,
cause you know they had to have some evil elites that lied to their people,
right?
Maybe they wanted to keep their tribes together.
So they said they created these monsters so you can't go out there.
We're going to protect you so you've got to stay here.
Wouldn't that be a good move for,
it's probably exactly what happened.
Right?
And they got these crazy stories of these monsters.
Yeah,
man,
you got to stay here.
They had protection.
CIA.
Yeah.
Native Americans.
Just Brown building empires.
One on one.
You create,
you scare them with aliens.
We got a threat from up here,
so we need to protect you.
And then we got threats down here.
Two jobs,
maybe jobs was a CIA movie.
Let's keep people out the ocean.
We got to keep them in the cities.
It's all CIA,
Bro.
Everything I is all powerful.
Imagine if they just worked for good instead of trying to,
you know,
what they do at the native American community.
People who are talking about AI,
automating programming have never really written serious code coding is thinking
it's automated,
structured thinking and AI that can program as well or better than humans is an
AI that just took over the world.
That's end game.
That's the end of the human species.
Uh,
and I can give you arguments why I don't think that's coming either.
Um,
people who are thinking,
and I know I'd take the opposite side from some very famous people in this
debate,
but we're nowhere near close to General Ai,
not in our lifetimes.
You don't have to worry about it.
Even in our lifetimes.
Really.
It's so overblown.
Uh,
it's a,
it's another,
it's a combination of Cassandra complex.
You know,
it's fun to talk about the end of the world combined with a god complex,
like people who have lost religion.
So they were looking for meaning in some kind of end of history.
Right.
Um,
the reason why I don't think AI is coming anytime soon is because a lot of the
advances and so called AI today or what we call narrow AI,
they really pattern machine learning to figure out like what is that object on
the screen or how do you find the signal in all that noise?
There's nothing approaching what we call creative thinking,
uh,
to actually model general intelligence.
You run into all kinds of problems first.
We don't know how the brain works at all.
Number two,
we've never even modeled a paramecium or an Amoeba,
let alone the human brain.
And number three,
there's this assumption that all of the,
uh,
computation is going at the cellular level,
at the neuron level,
whereas nature is very parsimonious.
It uses everything at his disposal.
There's a lot of machinery inside the cell that is doing calculations that is
intelligent,
that isn't accounted for.
And the best estimates are,
would take 50 years of Moore's law before we can simulate what's going on inside
a cell near perfectly and probably a hundred years before we can build a brain
that can simulate inside the cells.
So putting it at saying that I'm just going to model neuron is on or off and
then use that to build the human brain is overly simplistic.
Furthermore,
I would pause it.
There's no such thing as general intelligence.
Every intelligence is contextual within the context of the environment that it's
in,
so you have to evolve an environment around it.
So I think a lot of people who are peddling general AI,
the burden of proof is on them.
I haven't seen anything that would lead me to indicate we're approaching general
AI.
Instead,
we're solving deterministic,
closed,
set,
finite problems using large amounts of data,
but it's not sexy to talk about it.
If you come in last,
you give us called,
spread it out collectively $1 million.
You're doing better now.
It's 12 bucks champ tour bus champ.
You have to think about that.
I just sign up for,
you're not going to lose if those are the stakes.
What is the government division?
Wait,
hold on.
Hold on one second.
Let's let aside,
let's talk to bus.
Champ comes at a price.
Dude,
my bus was so fucking sick.
You can't just be tour bus champ or his daughters or his five.
I was two.
I was 12 I was chair.
Listen,
listen.
Do you understand that this is strange,
that you keep failing at these things and yet you keep bragging every time we
get together,
contemplate events.
So much success when it comes to you guys.
Then I think sometimes you guys forget about it.
I was trying to share [inaudible] shame.
[inaudible]
Nelson Alive,
don't you?
You're not the tour bus champ to bus that I was on this week is better than any
bucks championship was going on already asking me who's tour bus trip.
Let's say why it's me.
Of course I'll come cause I have the better bus.
Did you ever take a picture of your bus and put it online?
Yeah.
Oh really?
And you had fucking Photoshop to a hundred times.
No.
The outside of your bus doesn't count.
Tom,
the inside of your bus that looked like a prison yard didn't look like a prison
yard too.
Did not,
did not have a broken transmission.
No Internet TV's that didn't work.
You had no internet on your [inaudible].
Just the one and I want you to pause for a second and imagine a world where the
thing that you're bragging about when you have been called out for failing to
challenges in a row hard as fuck it makes it great.
The first thing you talking about is this.
We're not even in the shape of the bus that you drive around in.
I didn't start to my ship tour bus.
How much is prepared woods?
Was the transmission bad?
We'll then I when
I get a flat tire,
well then I had shit
show.
I'm Leonardo Dicaprio at the front of the titanic.
We,
we had a challenge who came in last you you're talking about flipped her over.
Totally.
Somebody was like,
what are the repercussions for you fucking pussing out?
Well,
I'm not posting your fucking founded.
The reasons why I have this right here is because I read about you saying that
you're going to put it on your mantle piece and I'm like,
that's never going to very or Mickey mantle piece.
Joe,
can you entertain you?
Can you entertain a circumstance in which you think Burt could beat you?
Hip Hop make,
make again like the old hustler make an even game where they could be anybody's
at this point,
like a pool game was always saying no,
no,
no.
When I play pool,
but like in the challenge that where it's like you've got to make it have to be,
I'd have to have some form of lymphoma
really wrong with me
if you want to bring together,
I don't know,
people who are on opera opposite opposite sides of the climate debate for
example.
Good luck,
I'm sure.
Right?
Well,
why is part part of that you could argue is if one side just does not accept
science,
how can you really bring those people together?
It doesn't mean you need physical conflict to resolve it.
In fact,
I completely agree with you.
The physical conflict is totally counterproductive,
but at a certain point on some issues,
I understand why there's like an intractability to the debate where it seems
completely impossible to move forward because whichever side you're on,
I would argue that I'm on the right side of these issues and others would
disagree.
When you're far apart in a way that you can't even agree as to like what the
starting point facts are about the conversation.
How do you even,
how do you start?
I have some ideas as to how I try to do it,
but it's very tough.
It's very tough.
I just don't think dunking on people always like constantly shitting on people
is necessarily the way to do it.
Yeah,
and I think it's important to distinguish between just straight up ad hominem
where someone is wrong and bad,
uh,
because I think they're a bad person or they're an idiot or whatever to
recognizing when somebody is a participant in bad faith and a conversation to
when someone has maybe fallen prey to audience capture or whatever else might be
kind of influencing what,
what and how they're doing.
I think that those criticisms are legitimate,
but you got to stay away from just ad Hominem.
When I woke up that morning,
I was about one 62.
I woke up at 5:00 AM way answer at 9:00 AM I have to be one 55.
So I've got seven pounds to to cut it,
which is okay.
You know,
it's not too bad.
Cut about nine pounds of the day before.
I'm a little dehydrated,
a little,
you know,
I'm a little already worn,
but uh,
as the way cut was going,
you know,
we got till about eight o'clock and I had only cut a pound and a half,
so I still want 61 in a half something at eight o'clock Wayne's or at nine
o'clock to the point where we got to do something.
So they start to put me in the bathtub just because we do most of our cuts in
the bath.
You know,
when you,
when you're in a high humidity,
you,
you're going to cut more water weight or are you going to sweat more?
And water is obviously a hundred percent humidity.
Um,
so they start throwing bull and hot water because we couldn't get the water hot
enough to make me sweat more Christ.
So we just take a kettle's of,
of hot water and just pouring it on me.
Uh,
and you know,
doctors are in analogies,
twin and 12 people in and out of the the,
the hotel room to make sure I'm okay.
Uh,
and I make sure that I could cut the weight and I was just in such a,
like an adrenaline fucking like on 10.
I'm like,
just get,
Oh,
you know,
I'm screaming at everybody on,
literally,
I was in the tub,
I was crying like,
why?
But to me,
I was like,
there's no way I'm not making this weight and six pounds in about an hour,
maybe two hours,
cause I go wait in about nine o'clock or so,
uh,
army,
about nine 30,
10 or so,
um,
six pounds in two hours.
This,
it was brutal.
But I think that just kept me as such a,
such a 10 or my adrenaline level.
I never really understood how to bring it back down,
you know?
And,
and rob would try and talk to me and try and tell me like,
hey,
calm down.
Like,
you know,
take a few deep breaths.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I'm breathing,
whatever.
I wasn't listening to it,
so,
hm.